so when they needed us we could find the
battles that they never could so tell me
where the Avengers are now because we're
you know you mentioned it where we last
left off things had kind of blown up a
little bit when we last you know saw
these characters and Civil War it's been
probably in two or three years that have
passed and our characters have been you
know kind of part of some sort of
counter terrorism efforts but we're you
know flying under the radar and you know
it's a lot I think when you are you know
on these kinds of missions with no
governmental support you don't really
have the support of even you know even
just the general public and you know
you're sort of running the rogue you
know trying to do what you know is best
for the common man but you're not you
know you don't have you don't have
someone to kind of guide you or like I
said support you and so that we're we
kind of are fractured ourselves you know
and then of course the last we saw Hulk
he was like floating into the
stratosphere now we are you know
reintroduced to this whole expanded
universe there's been a lot of change
that's gone on since the original
Avenger is assembled I feel like it's
bigger that they're bigger and better
and you know better than each one before
and this one is better in a good way
this one has 64 Marvel characters is it
really 64 that's mine and Anthony and
Joe they posted this aerial shot of
trailer village and it was like nothing
I've ever seen before have you guys seen
it
I mean it's just trailer yeah like half
of those are are DJs yeah that's true
actually yeah we actually it's kind of
like we're making three movies all at
once you know it's very plot driven
it's kind of this is a film I think that
really it you know all we have to all of
these pieces come together in a very
like in a kind of complex intricate
package and that's what this that's the
purpose I think of this film is to sort
of bring everything together in a
coherent way and so as that's happening
it feels sort of like there are kind of
three movies going on at once because we
meet different characters and different
circumstances and this one kind of
greater cause brings everyone together
and so it's we even haven't had the
opportunity to work with you know I mean
probably 75 percent of those 60 whatever
people just because you know their
characters are often some other having
some realm yeah it really takes
crossover to a whole new level
mm-hmm I mean Avengers guardians of the
galaxy and I'm thinking about that and
I'm thinking Chris Pratt sarcasm sarcasm
Robert Downey jr. sarcasm senior I mean
is it like a sarcastic off I think they
do a good job of taking you know and
sprinkling those guys around you know I
don't think they're pumped about brie
Larson is captain yeah oh yeah I got it
she's great I i I'm that's a very
welcome addition passing when will we
get a black widow movie um no no I I
don't know I mean I you know yes I would
want to in the right context and you
know for the film to fit where I'm in
you know I am in my life I'm you know
play this character for a long time it's
been probably like eight years or more
and um you know it's so much has
happened in my life and happening
as a performer happen in my life
personally and I think that you know it
would be theirs I love playing this
character and I think that there is
definitely an opportunity to explore the
widow as a you know as a woman who has
kind of come into her own and is making
independent and active choices for
herself
probably for once in her life you know
she hasn't always had that had that
possibility so if it fit though that
criteria they don't yes yeah I'm I'm
excited for even our the next infinity
where this thing really does go on
forever but you know we even get to it
will even be like a I think more of an
opportunity for as all these pieces come
together you know you know we'll really
have an opportunity to work you know
always kind of you know you're never
gonna guess we didn't see it so Maddie
hey everybody its charlie so Captain
America and Black Widow talking a little
bit about the Black Widow movie Secret
Avengers that happens in the time
between Civil War in Avengers infinity
war and that some of the stuff that's
going on during infinity war in Avengers
4 and how they shot those in a different
way like she says it felt like we were
shooting three movies if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the Marvel videos there's an
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway going on
right now all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video but the real big news I know
everyone's asking is as winner tickets
on sale because links are up on Fandango
movie tickets calm like theaters know
when they're gonna be showing the movie
times but you can't click through to buy
tickets yet that also goes hand-in-hand
with the next trailer they're going to
drop which will be like the hey here's
new footage you can now buy tickets
please click through on the ticket link
at the end of this video
like they always have that really
specific language at the end of those
trailers when they do start selling
tickets tickets available now click this
link here and it'll be like some link
that will pop up it take you
wherever to buy movie tickets that's the
whole reason for this next trailers are
gonna drop it's not because they want to
give you more footage if they didn't
have to drop a trailer to get people to
buy tickets then they wouldn't do it and
you don't have a phone no I don't have a
phone but you could have sent to the
electronic letter it's called an email
yeah do you have a computer no what for
we as fans of course we're gonna go see
the movie but we also want trailers so
it's a bit of a trade-off like we're
gonna sell you something but we'll give
you new footage in order to do it so
there's been a bunch of rumors there was
even people on Twitter saying that
theater owners were informed that they
could start selling tickets this Friday
now that's not confirmed but the NCAA
just started March Madness it's still in
the first round right now I assume that
they would wait till some of the bigger
games like the Final Four to drop
another trailer but if all these people
are saying the tickets go on sale on
Friday then that means that that's when
the next promo would draw remember the
next promo is just gonna be an
advertisement to get you to buy those
movie tickets but when Black Widows
talking about the three movies that they
were filming while this was all going on
she's really just referring to infinity
war itself not Avengers 4 because they
filmed those movies back to back so they
were basically on that lop or almost an
entire year I mean actors would come and
go as they needed to film scenes but
during infinity war there are so many
different Avengers teams all over the
place some up in space some in Wakanda
some in New York City so like none of
them all had a lot of scenes with
everybody else at the same time
on-screen which sounds like it'll change
for Avengers for like she says we were
like 75% of the people we didn't have
scenes with so they just confirms that
by the end of infinity Wars they all
converge there's this big battle in
Wakanda and then for the most part
Avengers 4 is all of them together as a
team or at least the Avengers that
survive because there's no way we're
gonna make it through infinity war
without at least one big character dying
the deal with the Black Widow movie is
that they've hired a screenwriter she's
already met with Scarlett Johansson what
they're probably doing is just working
on a draft of the script before Marvel
goes and shops for directors usually
they don't do that until they have a
really good draft of a script unless
they're looking for a director that can
also write the movie like James Gunn but
it sounds like in this case they're just
looking to get a draft
to the Black Widow movie then they'll go
about getting a director and then
they'll probably make some sort of
announcement about it so no idea if
that'll happen by Comic Con but what I'm
expecting Marvel comic con this year to
be all about is because ant-man and the
wasp will have already been released in
theaters it'll be all about Captain
Marvel because that will be the next
movie coming up so they'll drop a
trailer for that and for Avengers for
usually they have like two movies at
least that they drop footage for so next
two big movies are the next Avengers
film and Captain Marvel but there's a
whole bunch of other Marvel videos that
I'm working on obviously most of this is
infinity war centric because that's the
big thing right now but there was some
spider-man stuff that was just announced
he talked about crossing over with
sharees character so I might do a video
about that really soon
leave all your requests in the comments
below but what I'll do is whether or not
they drop a new trailer on Friday I will
be posting new Marvel so I'll announce
the giveaway winner when I post my next
Marvel video so no worries but you can
click here for that soul gem video that
I just did and you can click here for
the last big preview thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]